So, here I have the equation written,
and I've written it both ways.
Just the original the way using
the gradient imagery dot product way, or
in the algebraic way.
Question.
How many unknowns and
how many equations per pixel?
The number of unknowns is easy.
What was I trying to solve for?
U an v, right?
U and
v is which way is this point moving?
Great.
How many equations?
Well, yes, there are two equations up
there, but they're the same equation.
I have two unknowns, but
only one equation per pixel.
This should bother you, all right?
It's very hard to solve things that
you've got twice as many unknowns as you
have equations, because remember,
I have a different u and v possibly for
every pixel.
So I've got 2 times the number
of pixels unknowns, and
I've got one equation per pixel,
2 times the number of pixels.
What's going on here?
So intuitively we can think about what
this constraint means as follows.
The component of u v that's in
the direction of the gradient,
that's what we can measure, right?
That amount will tell us how
much the image will change.
That's why that's the amount of It I
sub t, the derivative, all right?
So what this is saying is if this is the
direction of our gradient as indicated
here, right, here it,
suppose this is my real u,v right there.
Well any other u, v
that has a component of the same
amount in the direction,
but I've got a u prime v prime,
that's in an extra component that's
parallel to the edge, all right?
And this new vector here, which was
the original u, v plus u prime v prime,
it has the same amount
perpendicular to the edge, in the,
in the direction of the gradient, but
a different amount along the edge.
Remember when we were doing corner
finding and we put up the thing and
we said, well if you slide it up and
down, on fu, if, whe,
if your little patch is on the edge of,
of the black square.
If we slide it up and
down, we can't tell at all.
We can only tell how much is being
moved perpendicular to the edge.
That's what's going on here.
Locally, we can only
tell the amount of motion
that is perpendicular to
the edge in a little area.
When you think about this little area,
you can think of it like
looking through a little hole.
Remember, from our talk about cameras,
that that's called an aperture.
And this general problem,
this is called the aperture problem.